véritable attraction pour certains cette
rivière est une épée de damoclès pour
les habitants du prêcheur depuis janvier
les alertes au lard rythment la vie de
la commune
on a peur on a toujours peur d'être des
complices ou la menthe à la montagne est
un peu grise comme ça on a peur et ça ok
à tous les dégâts et puis on est on est
aux nerfs pour éviter le pire le curage
et quasi quotidiens depuis janvier le
système d' alerte reste en éveil
ce matin état et collectivités acteurs
de la gestion de crise était réunie au
prêcheur les préconisations des deux
missions menées par des experts en avril
ont été présentés on parle de 100 mille
mètres cubes en termes d'enrochement à
réaliser on parle de digues pour
protéger en berge gauche et quartier
coquette épaules mais aussi en berge
droite le quartier des abymes bref vous
voyez des aménagements beaucoup plus
lourd et beaucoup plus conséquent les
enrochements et les digues devront
courir sur une distance de 2 km 500
entre la mer et le premier gain
cet aménagement des berges là sont
vraiment des mesures de
assez lourd dont on parle de 5 millions
d'euros donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je vais mobiliser
maintenant bien évidemment
les ministères notamment celui de la
transition écologique pour la
municipalité les risques naturels sont
si importants qu'il faut préparer un
réaménagement global
nous envisageons et nous en avons parlé
aujourd'hui avec notre projet d'école
les deux déplacements de de la zone
urbaine de fraîcheur à l'antenne il faut
envisager effectivement la
relocalisation du bourg par rapport non
seulement à l'exposition l'art mais
aussi par rapport à l'exposition jusqu'à
littoraux en attendant le plan d'action
à long terme
le curage continue la ctm en charge des
opérations a évacué plus de 150 mille
mètres cubes de matériaux en oeuvre